speakers today need no introduction but
let me still introduce final good luck
and if you did anything with proof
complexity you
of a start circuit you've seen pavel's
name
over and over and over again and uh from
um from lower bounds from feasibility
violation i think your name is the most
overbound
complexity that i can think of cutting
planes uh
the seminal result has lower bounds for
chitin planes
um from the point of view of
methamasemytic
uh pavel has a great book called
mathematics of first order arithmetic
and a more recent book
which is a gentle introduction
the logical foundation of mathematics
and complexity
it's gentle but it still talks about a
lot of
really um advanced concept
that uh sasha mentioned uh also
if you do algorithm for sat
uh probably the most well known uh
algorithm for south
um exponential algorithm is ppac
and again this is pagel's work
so many things that i can't even mention
all of them circuit complexity other
connections
so i'd rather let i will talk about
this and the beautiful connection
between different areas of complexity
and stuff
please thank you antonina for
a very flattering introduction
so my talk will be uh hopefully short
and definitely very elementary
uh i will not talk about
new stuff i will actually talk about it
i have already spoken a couple of times
but each time i still find
some details that
i can present in a better way or
complement things in it
so
let's start with some background from
the foundations of
mathematics we use various theories to
formalize arithmetic or set theory
[Music]
these theories are of increasing
strength
here on the slide we have t2 which is
bounded arithmetic so i should have also
included s12 that was mentioned before
which is a
fragment of t2 then we have
a fragment of piano arithmetic called i
sigma 1 which is induction for sigma 1
formulas
a stronger theory than that is the piano
arithmetic is
the so-called second order arithmetic
which is not
arithmetic formulas in in this in
the second order uh
proof calculus because there is no any
but it's uh
it's a an extension of piano arithmetic
by
the sets uh subsets of
interpret interpreted as subsets of
integers
non-negative integers then a thermal
franco theory
and we can go on by adding new axioms
such a strongly inaccessible cardinal or
the existence of measurable characters
and obtain stronger and stronger
theories
and these theories are stronger we can
prove that they are stronger because
[Music]
of uh gadoth theorem and they in fact
prove more uh
true pi one sentences assuming that
these theories
are are true that they describe the true
uh true
sentences of arithmetic
but the question that is
interesting for us is whether they prove
more sentences relevant to
computational complexity this is what
you would like to know
so this is one thing that we can ask and
another thing is if you take some
theories that uh differ in
in a way like uh p
differs from np and np differs from
uh sigma 2p and so on
uh then we can ask whether this
theorists
form an increasing hierarchy and this is
uh open and probably very difficult
problem because here we cannot apply
uh greater theorem of course
we cannot prove that we cannot apply the
theorem but
we know we know one thing that the
consistency of this theories
is so strong that
none of these theories prove the
consistency of the the weakest one so we
cannot use
the consistency to separate these
theories
uh here's an example
of what i am very much interested in
[Music]
given a problem and an algorithm that
solves p
what is the weakest theory that proves
the soundness of
a by the soundness of a i mean that the
the algorithm solves the problem
or uh given a problem in a time bounty
you can ask her what is the biggest
theory
circuit for some algorithm prove that a
source
p in time t
uh here is an example that
uh appeared in in our paper long time
ago
uh if factoring is hard then
uh the theory denoted by s12 which sasha
mentioned
briefly does not prove the sadness of
any polynomial time algorithm for
primality
so we are in the situation that we do
know that there is a polynomial time
algorithm for primality
but assuming a reasonable conjecture the
s12
doesn't prove the service of this
algorithm so it's conceivable that
[Music]
there are algorithms that are so
complex or tricky or
like use deep mathematics that
they they are not provable in weak
systems uh of arithmetic or set theory
so for instance here we are not able to
prove the soundness of
aks algorithm in any fragment of t2
but at the same time we we don't have a
reason to
believe that it is not provable in in
t2 except that we don't know how to do
it but
there may be ways to argue that
it's not possible by placing
these things into a hierarchy of
total function and p problems but i am
digressing so
uh here's what i mean by someness of an
algorithm
[Music]
uh so we have to be careful how we
formalize these questions
we can always formalize uh an algorithm
so that uh
zfc or any any fixed theory does not
prove a soundness we can just
embed uh the consistency statements of
this theory
into the algorithm and then we are not
able to prove that
it is sound
but we can ask the opposite question
or something formally opposite
is it possible to formalize every
algorithm that
its soundness is provable in parallel
arithmetic
or some other fixed theory
now this question is
vague and unfortunately
i'm not able to formalize it in a way so
that
it doesn't have a trivial answer but
this is what i would be very much
interested
so instead i will show today some
related things that are not exactly this
question
but of the same nature
what i i'm going to present
is something that can be uh
presented as syntactic
classes versus semantic classes
syntactic classes
do have complete problems while semantic
classes
usually do not
and we usually
are not able to prove that that there is
no complete problem
but uh we can argue that there are some
good reasons to believe that there are
no complete problems
and what i'm going to talk about it is
three conjectures or several conjectures
that are of the form that
saying that there are no complete
problems in certain
classes
russell impeller doesn't like the word
conjecture because
he suggests to grow things hypothesis
but in this case
it's something that i uh very much
believe that
they are true we should eventually be
able to prove it
like we believe that p is not equal
entity
so we don't say that
is a hypothesis
what is the semantic can you define
semantic class
okay
so a semantic class
is a class that is defined in such a way
that
we have to prove the defining condition
that
the problem belongs to the the class so
for instance
p is a syntactic class because we can
present every polynomial algorithm
in such a way that we know from
the code that you write down that it
runs in polynomial time
this is not
the definition is not a syntactic but if
we
if you put into the code of the
of the algorithm a clock that
that will stop the algorithm
after polynomial number of steps then we
know for sure and
that it will stop after plenty of time
and
the dog makes noise here i will have to
do something
but other classes
typically uh randomized classes
are not of this form you write down an
algorithm and you
uh accept this as a
definition of the of a set in this class
if you prove that it accepts the
input with certain probability or not
sorry i have to make a short way
to see what's going wrong
the dog doesn't have a mute button no
okay so he's now quiet okay so let's go
on
no my question is when we use the monty
class we're actually very loose about it
because i can always ask when you say
all the all the algorithms in some
running sometimes saying what theoretic
universe are you talking about
so my claim is that when we use the
monthly classes we are really very loose
and if we try to be precise we will have
to
be better defined into saying what class
of models are we talking about
well i i don't understand this so i i
think that the
semantic class is defined precisely a
lot like
rp bpp because they they may be equal to
p and then they are not
semantic anymore because they can be
defined synthetically but uh
otherwise they are
semantic so um
excuse me
foreign
sorry so this dog is is very clever you
can open the doors
so it's difficult to contain him
somewhere
so anyway
this is not another precise definition
but
but we will see examples and maybe
it will be better to look at the
examples that i will
present is it okay uh rochelle
yes sasha just gave a good a good answer
i'm happy with his answer
okay
yes maybe so
you have to say uh uh said in the chats
90 there is no recursive enumeration of
machines computing languages from this
class
i say it again uh there is no recursive
enumeration
of machines computing languages from
this class
yes yes the the reason why why we do
have
complete problems in synthetic classes
is because we can enumerate
the the algorithms of course
it may not work always because the
enumeration
may be not so so effective but but this
is just
a rule of thumb it's not not a precise
statement
so let's get to the examples so the the
first
uh item on
my list or in the title is the
set of pathologies so let's
uh restrict to dnf technologies but
this is not important just to be
more concrete we have
proof systems and a proof system is
something that is complete that there is
a proof for every
pathology and sound that
it doesn't prove for non-pathologies
the completeness is easy to ensure by uh
embedding some um well-known proof
system
in into it and then uh say if we believe
that the resolution is complete then we
can
add to each proof system resolution and
then
we know that it is complete
based on the assumption that resolution
is complete
and we don't have to prove essentially
anything
but the soundness is a problem so if you
have a
very strong proof system then
you have to prove that it is sound it's
not it may be
a non-trivial thing
so this is uh how they are defined and
then we have
uh polynomial simulations i'll not
define them because we we
know this very well that you can if you
have one proof system
and the other proof system simulates
this proof system means that you can
assimilate the proofs of one system in
the other
so there is polynomial time function
that translate
translates proof system from one into
the other
and the conjecture is that
this condition of soundness
is indeed indeed syntactic that we
cannot uh
prove it easily which means that there
is now consistent here that proves the
soundness of all proof systems
so this this may be one possible
statement of this
conjecture and
which is not maybe completely obvious
but
easy that this is equivalent to the
condition that there is no
proof system that simulates all other
proof systems
i will call this optimal proof systems
an optimal proof system is that
simulates all proof systems and also i
am
omitting the specification polynomial
so similarize mean polynomialism was
affected with that
life time computable functions i will
not talk about
the length of proofs
your red syntactic should be semantic
right
what did you say syntactic yes
this this should be semantic thank you
thank you
yes
i have a kind of selective blightness i
cannot
proof read my slides
your slides are semantic not syntactic
so uh okay and this conjecture is a
fairly strange
strong conjecture because in particular
it
implies that exponential time is not
equal to non-deterministic exponential
time
and this is probably stronger than
p is not equal to mp
there is a related class which is the
class of
disjoint and p sets so this class
consists of
pairs of sets a b which are
in p and that they are disjoint
again we can define polynomial
reductions between
uh two elements of this class
this is quite natural we can use either
turing reductions or many one
which means that if we have two pairs
then the first set should be mapped into
the
first set of the other and the second
should be met
into the to the other so this is
something
that you can easily imagine
[Music]
and now the condition that these two
sets are
disjoint is a semantic
semantic condition i have to be careful
not to confuse the
two things semantic because uh
if you write down the definitions of
these sets
you don't know whether they are addition
unless
you write down some trivial think like
like
all the sets in a start with zero all
the sets in b
start with one so that these are easily
recognizable but it's easily
recognizable that they are determined
but
in general it may be hard to prove that
they are disjoint
so we can state the conjecture that
there is no complete disjoint empty pair
and this conjecture again is equivalent
to
this statement that there is no
consistent theory that
proves the dissonantness of all the
discharged energy pairs
now i'm stating this
conjecture at least the the second part
is stated
bit not quite precisely because what
does it mean
that the theory doesn't prove that there
is not disjoint
uh this whether the theory proves that
the
the
peristation definitely depends on how
you formalize
in these pairs so you need to write down
a formula if you want to
talk about its probability
so to state this precisely if i would
need to say that
it does not prove the disjointness of
all np pairs uh however you
formalize the pair so you take the the
best formalization
for which it should be the the easiest
way to prove that they are designed and
for for this you are still not
able to prove it in some theory
i mean you prefer you're still not able
to prove it in the theory
all right so uh how
how are these conjectures are connected
to show that they are connected
uh one can use the
very important concept of
canonical pairs of proof systems if
we have a proof system p
then the canonical pair of the proof
system as defined by sasha is
uh consists of a set of
basically you can view it as
four guns that are that have short
proofs but
to be more precise what we use so we are
using
padding that limits the
the length of proof so it's a pair of
formula and uh
a number represented in a unary
such that fee doesn't have
feed v has a refutation of length
at most n and the second set
is basically sad but uh
we need something that looks uh similar
to
ap so we also use padding but
it is just a padding that
does nothing so this
pair somehow captures the the strength
of the proof system
because if p simulates q then uh
the pair corresponding to q is
polynomially reducible to
pair corresponding to p
this is this
is very easy to prove uh
and the corollary of this is that uh
the conjecture about division np pairs
implies uh the conjecture about
proof systems for prepositional
tautologies
now let's let's get to
[Music]
total function p
so t f np means total function and p
[Music]
which i define in the following way
[Music]
a problem in total function and p is
given by a binary
relation that is computable in
polynomial time
and a polynomial bound
such that the relation
defines where multivalued
but total function that is for for every
a there is
b which is at most polynomially
longer than a such that it satisfies
the relation so this polynomial bound is
given
just to be quite precise
but typically the polynomial bound is
already
implicit in the relation r so i will
often omit this permanent bound and talk
only about the
relation the problem associated with
this
relation which has this property is to
find
for a given a to find b such that
it satisfies the relation
so now again this
this condition is
uh semantical
you if you have a definition if you
there's a formula for
r or a polynomial time algorithm
computing this binary relation
you never know for sure that
this defines
a total function so you have to prove in
some theory
now again we we have reductions between
these problems
now i will just use r and r prime
for for these problems and then these
relations
this reduction are defined in the
obvious way we have
there are many one relations or during
relations
and it makes no difference for for the
conjecture
it can go into state so
this many one reduction is given by
two polynomial time computable functions
f
and g so you want to compute
a witness for a in
relation r and you can do in in such a
way that you first compute
f a and find the witness for f prime
and from this witness b and a
you you get the witness for a in in
relation r
but it may be more complicated to just
using
oracle for for the solution of r prime
anyway so so we have a
class and we have reductions and then we
can ask
whether there is a complete problem
but uh let's uh
just take an example so that we we are
sure that this concept
is not empty there are probably
[Music]
total function and p that are not
solvable in that time
because if everything is solvable in
polynomial time then
everything will be reduced reducible to
everything so
uh then there will be a complete problem
so factoring is an easy example
of a problem that is not solvable
in polynomial time
but it's based on the assumption that it
is hard
so so the hardness of factoring simply
means that
uh this total function gp problem is not
released
to be uh computed by
so we have at least two different uh
types of total function np problems
those that are solvable important time
and those that that are not
uh the conjecture about total function
and p is are much
stronger than that
than just saying that there are problems
that are not soluble in polynomial time
the conjecture is that there is no
complete other functional
problem it is far more
uh stronger than saying that
there is one problem that is not
solvable
and again this can be stated
equivalently
in logic that there is no consistent
theory that
proves totality of all total
function and p problems
uh these are of course hopeless
conjectures because
they they imply p and q and p
so do we have any reasons to believe
that
they are true
[Music]
one reason why i believe is this
is true is that it's very much like uh
the
like computable functions in
probably total computable functions in
theories
if you have increasing theories with
increasing strength
then you can show that also
the class of probably total computable
functions increases in the structural
series
it does not have to increase always
increase but
at least in the examples that i showed
at the beginning that this is the case
so the the only difference here is that
in total function and p everything is
polynomial
well here it is computable so this
formal similarity is one reason
to believe that it may be
true the other reason is that we
already have characterizations of
probably total functions
uh probably total
np functions in fragments of bounded
arithmetic
and these characterizations are of
increasing complexity
we cannot show that they are
of increasing complexity indeed but
at least formally the recent complexity
unfortunately we are still not able to
prove that at least in
relativized world they are of increasing
complexity
so this is one of the big open problems
in
in proof complexity to show that
the desired key of total function and p
problems is
increasing this is something that is
not hopeless i believe that it only
requires
proving some very complicated switching
plans
but so far nobody was able to do this
uh like with
a set of technologies we also have
a similar connection which are disjoint
co-np pairs of vision
current pieces
again polynomial reductions and q ring
on many one
are defined in the same way
and we can stay the conjecture that
there is no complication currently there
again it's uh it's a syntactic class so
uh this is equivalent to
if through that then there is no
uh fixed year that proves precisionness
of
all kind of peoples
and we have a similar connection
as before namely that the conjecture
about
addition grumpy pairs implies
the conjectures about total function
and p problems
so the situation so far is
that
uh we have two branches of conjectures
one is uh about pathologies and vision
and prepares and
another is about total function and p
and
vision can be bears
but sat is still missing and
you can now guess where sat is
it's not obvious so we will look at
what it said so i want to spend a little
more time with sad because
this is a program
in simus simons which is
focus on sub
so sat is of course very much different
from
thought but we also can
consider proof system for foresight and
a proof system
what is a proof system for that it's
just any evidence that proves that
a formula is satisfiable
what are polynomials simulations they
are exactly
same as for photons that you transform
proof in one proof system
into another into a proof in
another proof system in polynomial time
but the difference is that
there is a the standard proof system
one very special proof system and this
is
just satisfying assignments if you want
to show that
a formula is satisfiable then the best
you can do is to provide a satisfying
assignment and this
this this proof system is polynomial
bounded
while we believe that there is no
polynomial bounded proofs
for uh tautologies we we have a
trivially polynomially bounded
sorry i i thought i was uh i i'm sorry
we've been quite relaxed but just
realized sorry
okay i i don't have many slides and i
skip something so i
will finish five minutes or it's okay or
hold on sorry for that i just looked at
the talk
oh yes
so
[Music]
okay so we so the situation
is different uh
but still uh there may be processes that
are not
polynomial bounded
now um an example of a proof system
first that is probably not
polynomially assimilable by by the
standard proof system
is the following one you you take the
standard proof system
and you add basically
factoring into it which means that you
take is a proof uh
any satisfying assignment or if the
the formula expresses that n is not a
prime
then n will be just the proof of this
and it is not difficult to see that if
factoring is hard then the standard
proof system
does not simply simulate the system
because if it did
then we would need to we would get the
satisfying assignment
for for formula five
and this is what uh what we believe is
not possible
all right so um
let me quickly go over this uh
natural proof system for sat
you can get natural proof system for sat
if you realize that
uh flies inside if the existential
existentially quantified formula as a
quantified tautology
is quantified tautology and then you can
use proof system for quantified
technologies
and you have to go faster
[Music]
what is interesting that the standard
proof system polynomial is the g-star
one
[Music]
details about it and the point is that
um
is the the witnessing theorem of of cook
so the bottom line
is that if you have a witnessing theorem
in a proof system
then it essentially means that
the the standard proof system will
normally simulate it
okay and if there is an optimal proof
system for saturn that looks
a complete problem in total fashion np
i wanted to prove this but i don't have
time so
it's a pity because it's a simple proof
so let me finish by saying that
we can stay the conjecture the sub
doesn't have an optimal proof system
and what the proof that we skipped
gives us that total function and p
conjectures
implies the subconjecture so we can
place
sat into the diagram and it is between
p and equal and p and total function and
p conjecture
now and these things
so we know that many things are
different
in particular these two branches are
really
distinct branches
but unlike showing these implications
which are usually
easy and more or less straightforward
relativizations are pretty
technical and complicated so we still
don't know whether
these two are different and these two
are different
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you so much well this is really
really interesting
okay uh we are a little bit over time
but but
[Music]
so harvey friedman has this program
showing that this
stronger set theories end up proving
kind of a you need stone set theory to
prove very
mathematically looking statement about
kind of numbers just statement about
numbers here and things like that
and i wonder whether you can use this
program to
show that these stronger sets theory
like axiom
cardinal strong cardinal axioms
prove things that actually they have
computational meaning
uh i wish i could but they cannot
yeah so
the the problem is that essentially what
we what we are able to
to do is just somehow to
rephrase uh the consistency
uh in in some combinatorial way
but it's not
it's not anything that can be
interpreted as a
statement about computational complexity
but but this is well
i would like to do it and i'm thinking
about it
but i don't know how to do it
thank you i think yes thank you so much
and uh maybe while
uh try you know if anybody has any more
questions
and thank you so much this is fantastic
this is really interesting
i may ask you a question pavel thank you
for the talk first of all
uh my question is the following consider
the conjecture
that p at that np intersect coin p which
is a monthly class
has no complete problem where would this
conjecture fit
in your diagram of
connections between the conjectures uh
this doesn't fit into any of the
branches
so it's uh it's in the middle it's it's
uh stronger than
of course uh pianic or np but it's in
the middle so we are
i i'm not sure that we can uh
show by relativization that it is not
in any of the branches maybe if chronic
if he's connected can
can tell you more but it seems that this
is in between
thank you
it's possible that there is a third
branch which is
based on this but uh you know
other than this problem
in this direction so sorry for
being a bit longer than oh
i'm sorry for kind of making it more
loose it needs to be thank you so much
for watching